[Applaudissements]
à
l'équipe comment ils vont la jouer six
jeux suivants la chouette
on va à l'homme très exactement et on va
faire une avant première de touche 4
aller au cinéma c'est très important
avec un masque et si vous allez voir les
tuche vous allez beaucoup rigolé le mas
qui va faire
[Musique]
bonjour ça va
rené salut
ab
jacques kivu
aussi
tables et 6 mafia est partout c'est
dingue ça sont partout les jets 3 puis 7
10 c'est trop c'est moins cher
la
journée va être bien mais là on fait un
maquillage tout pour l'achever les
interviews normal d'abord et puis après
on se prépare pour en touche
quasi tous ses marchés eh ben
bienvenue à kinepolis est pour l'avant
première étuve 4 on vous souhaite un bon
film et on vous souhaite de joyeuses
fêtes de noël aulas du chu
bah ça va vous êtes là ben voila tu as
vu regarde j'ai déjà un peu raser
j'ai mis un pantalon noël c'est pas mal
l amiral mamy d'autre fera un regard
bien marsan 24 ans il ya le pantalon de
noël sinon allemagne deux flux d'almamy
mais c'est mieux pendant noël il
sait bien où il ya ça de son blog
peut-être c'est bio le bleu je peux tout
mettre en même temps mais ça y est ça
pousse et colorée mieux ses affaires tu
regardes à perdre que jeff tuche
ils vont me la posent et là je vous
laisse faire la coiffeuse basque etc il
faut faire gaffe c'est en plus ils
peuvent signer vrais cheveux c'est hyper
fragile donc je vais au bal avec juste
là j'ai rasé un peu tu veux à l'affiner
rejeté au sénat
gmail ou pantalons de noël vient là ma
belle via la samba
tu vas avoir déjà le costume assez
confiant parce qu'elle a un accent
les fausses barbes au cinéma il fausse
moustache c'est un enfer parce que ça se
décolle tous donc c'est vraiment galère
donc je préfère la laisser pousser et
ont la taille puis pendant deux mois
j'ai j'oublie en léger la moustache de
jeff tuche dans la vieux
tu partie sa main d'accord revoir
récemment
le personnage vêtu filet il est toujours
avec moi c'est un personnage que je fais
qui vient de mon enfance de gens que
j'entendais parler tout donc c'est un
peu une musique que j'ai dans la tête
comme une langue si tu veux comme
quelqu'un qui est qui est bilingue et
qui parce qu'il a entendu une langue
toute son enfance donc c'est un peu le
même façon de faire donc ça revient très
vite
on dira c'est un déguisement donc c'est
comme si tu es après tu es un peu tu
étais tellement libre un peu après parce
que quand on jeff tuche tue pas on peut
tout dire je suis pas content expliqué
tu as une liberté beaucoup plus évolué
ça c'est bien un peu là un peu non
apparu moi j'ai pas mal mais là c'est un
peu la fête s'il te plait je ne savais
pas que j'effectue si ça avait un blond
vénitien
elle adore c'est très élégant pour jeff
tuche tu sais que quand on a fait que tu
che 1 sandra donc la costumière mais
elle a galéré pour retrouver une
entrevue pas de bananes ya dix ans
c'était des mots des personnes en
avaient l galéré sur des sites pour
trouver une banane est aujourd'hui
maintenant ma part tous à la mode
saül avait improvisé ça et on est mort
de rire à se dire ici avec bonhomme dans
la banane et attendre en tournée
mais il nous fallait des mini ban a cédé
petite bande est tout petit et on
étouffe un fond d'eux on a envoyé
l'accessoire je trouve que des petites
bananes pourries c'est un péché pas coin
km tout ça pour une vanne pour sortir
une banale d'une banane
d'avenir la panne
iberdrola balmont
il faut que j'ai su s'il est mort de
rire de ça non le pire qu'on a eu c'est
quand on tourne aux états unis il avait
fait venir une nevada ce qu'un apport
aux etats-unis' existe pas cette voiture
qui ont fini en cargo à moi vois premier
gens autour avec la nevada dans le
désert donc c'est accessoiristes
américains qui la met en place qui
viennent me voir et qui me disent voilà
la nevada où je vais faire une arrivée
me dise voilà on vous l'a mise préfère
l'arrivée sauf qu'elle a un problème
technique l on peut pas on ne peut pas
faire on peut reculer avec donc vous
tourner coupé et puis on vous la
poussera à la main on leur mettra je dis
ok je tourne
je tourne je fais la scène je passe sort
du champ que s'arrêtent les mecs
arrivent vite quoique quoi et je fais tu
série clac clac et je recule il n'avait
pas sauvé mais savent pas ils sont
automatiques ou prennent orient
il édite des jeux par l'ancienne c'est à
la jeff tuche a
bien besoin à tous merci bassila venu
mais c'est beau tout bien on fait du
début wes mois l'homme
et la femme alors suite un réseau excuse
moi bien sûr la femme aussi c'est qu'il
faut il faut respecter la charité
acheta guillou tout jeune et où
exactement et la mode free ça se mange
avec quoi ça se mange un grâce aux
samouraïs la sauce qui pique nique
appliquée depuis tellement forte a les
yeux qui piquent sa balle
la chance d'avoir ici ce soir
[Applaudissements]
à
en catimini
[Applaudissements]
l'église
il a souri je suis ils vont la jouer
bonjour
alors qu'est ce que vous faites à tous
oui on y va
tu veux je vous vois quoi
[Applaudissements]
à
et bien sûr après deux tours
lol
[Applaudissements]
oh
c'est le nord est et les touches c'est
dingue c'est ornans
ouais
attention les celi tout c'est vous et
caméras déjà fait écouter
des salsifis
par ici par ici
c'est génial c'est ainsi que sans dire
pour les tuche 3 on était venu et
c'était de la folie comme ça ouais
c'était comme ça déjà un peu mais là
c'est encore plus con et en tue donc les
gens il s'y attendait pas si une
surprise
puisque pour rappel
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir lee
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop bien mais je pense que
d'énergie vitale j'aurais tout donné
c'était super les gens ils ont juste
envie de vous donner quoi pour qu'on
leur donne aussi donc c'est cool quoi
c'est à lille à chaque fois c'est comme
ça donc c'est vraiment très rassurant
pour nous ça nous fait ça nous fait
chaud au coeur on se dit que avec des
accueils comme ça le film vraiment
marcher un minimum ou quoi mais ouais
c'est très touchant c'est très émouvant
chaque fois je sais c'est émouvant de
voir ces gens
aussi dingue de cette famille ça nous
dépasse comptant les gens étaient
contents et tout ça qui compte c'est que
ça
abbas et puis c'est plus nous on veut
c'est lui qui toujours public qui décide
où on est
proposent ils disposent
[Musique]